[Music]
it's quarter to three there's no one in
the place except you and me make it one
for me one more head job once I was good
at it I know what do you want I want to
ask you some questions a story the
themes the stunning visual environments
it was a pleasure getting back to the
world of Blade Runner yeah where are we
going
[Music]
when I'd read the original Blade Runner
35 years ago and could never imagine how
iconic would still be I have massive
respect for of the world
Ridley Scott created dead runner
revolutionized the way we view science
fiction
when I heard that Ridley was continuing
the narrative I was already invested I
already wanted to know what happened
next I think it's kind of fun to play a
character 30 years later used to trying
on old clothes happily they still fit
from the cinematography to the script to
working with Denis and Ridley Roger
Harrison
Ryan I just feel really lucky just to be
on the team
[Music]
I never felt that much pressure of my
shoulders thinking that released that
will see this movie I've never worked on
a film with so many sets and different
lighting patterns technically Scott Xiao
Qi they created this incredible world
where there was a living breathing
universe designing this was like walking
on a knife's edge riding the line
between the original film and what we're
doing now it's not just a replica of the
first film we're marrying the familiar
with slightly divergent in order to give
ourselves an identity we're trying to
keep the visual effects very reality
based and grounded
people should look at it go well it's a
beautiful shot how did they get it
I always told you they're special
your story isn't over yet
the first movie is also meant to be a
standalone film there's always more to
tell them that two hours will allow we
are making something special
[Music]
it feels like a very grounded realistic
extension of the original it's good to
be home again
would you bring no one I know you're
here
this is impossible
[Music]
every civilization was built off the
back of a disposable workforce but I can
only make so many happy birthday there
is an order to things
that's what we do here
we keep order
[Music]
the world is built on a wall that
separates kind
tell either side there's no wall
you bought a war
[Music]
you're a cop
not at your job once
it was good
I know what do you want I want to ask
you some questions
the key to the future
is finally honest
bring your telly
you know you're here
[Music]
I always told you you're special your
story isn't over yet
there's still a page left
[Music]
you